[Music]  [Music]  i've been married  for almost 50 years so  my wife knows what it's like to be a  writer and she also knows what it's like  to be a writer's wife i  really wanted to say something about how  a long-term marriage creates its own  booya moon people outside that marriage  don't see into it  any couple that's been together for a  long period of time  has an understanding of each other  that's deeply private  i don't think narratives usually focus  on  the person that is next to that author  and how that person has a very  huge impact this show tries and aims  to be there and understand and connect  with that world  [Music]  stephen king marries both epic and  intimate  really beautifully  wow  [Music]  i never talk about my childhood how bad  was it  pretty damn bad  you